I mean is there a chance that unfreedom
will scream to audiences in your home
country of India anytime soon doesn't
look like but we are fighting for it so
I've filed a High Court case you know
against what censor board has done and
so we're hoping that some outcome will
come out of it I've started a petition
campaign I'm asking people to you know
come together in India and and then
fight against the censorship right I
have to ask since you you know you said
previously that you spent half a decade
working on the film and and it's a
beautiful film and there's so many
scenes that are important and I seen the
scenes that are the ones that it seems
like the censor board does not like but
knowing that prior to finishing the film
did you ever think twice about maybe
modifying those scenes or omitting them
altogether or you felt that you needed
them in there no I I don't censor myself
okay yeah I mean so the role of
censorship is to self-censor make
filmmakers self censor but you know I I
I didn't come to cinema to to do that I
came with a certain expression and then
I made a film with that I never even
thought that I should be doing it some
other way right so there was no there no
doubt in your mind knowing the censors
and and maybe prior films that have been
held up for similar reasons because I
believe it's only the sex scenes that
are the issue right not the violence or
some of the religious references no no
no it's not just a sexy oh it's not you
know I that that was very clear to me
that you know when it comes to you know
nudity of a certain kind I mean it would
the indian censor board would have a
problem you know and i you know it's
there's a way to address that though i
was never going to accept the cuts
anyways but the problem here is is not
that the problem is when you take sex
and violence and you you mix it with
religion and politics and you mix with
the truth of the society that's what is
becoming the
a problem for them that's what they
cannot digest so it's not just you know
it's just not nudity on screen that's
bothering them it's the ideas it's the
expression that the film has is it's
it's it's what it stands for is what
problematic for them and the
homosexuality in the fear I mean as we
understand that homosexuality is illegal
in India recently Supreme Court you know
passed a decision that homosexuals will
stay criminals in India and it's just
it's it's sad and it need to be fought
against yeah speaking of criminals you
say that you feel as a filmmaker you're
almost being penalized in a sense and
going before a jury and you feel as if
you are a culprit in wanting to show a
certain story and that you have to sort
of defend against that well I think all
Indian filmmakers are I mean in the way
censorship is set I mean we make a film
we have to the moment we make a film we
have to first go in front of this jury
that's gonna tell us what should stay in
the film or not
I mean it's absurdity of highest kind
are we the filmmakers or they are the
filmmakers you know so it's just not me
who feel like a criminal filmmaker I
mean I think every every Indian
filmmaker should I don't know if they
don't but you know in my opinion this is
this is just just completely wrong I
mean we are here to do to make our art
yet we are here to express our soul
through our cinema I mean who are these
moral guardians who are gonna tell us
you know what we should make and what
India should see it's not right have you
researched other filmmakers that have
gone before the board and had their
films denied or held up and what have
you seen what parallels have you seen
well when it comes to India this is
usually the case that film makers will
make their film they go to censor board
you know that there are certain
filmmakers who have been little
aggressive in their work who you know
kind of want to push that look you know
a censored what we'll come up with you
cut this you cut that and hence once you
do that you will get a certificate or
whatnot and a filmmakers usually give
into that I mean they just usually
accept those curves and and move on
because there is so much at stake you
know I mean there's money of investors
at stake Studios money at stake all the
you know all the I mean one film is made
with the cooperation of so many people
you know everybody wants Exim to go out
and and genuinely so so I understand
where those filmmakers come from but
that's not me you know I mean I always
not gonna accept that and leading to
that you've started a change.org
petition is that right which is is that
still current yes so unfreedom movie.com
which is which is the website you can go
on the homepage and click and you'll go
to change dot o-r-g where the petition
is and you know we want everybody to
sign that petition and and not just
Indian syenite I think it's it's a
censorship is not a issue that India is
facing and the kind of world we live in
it's it's a global issue you know you
violate human rights at one place and
and you will see the repercussions of it
in other countries and we see that so so
my appeal is to everybody in the world
who who kind of bill who completely
believes in absolute freedom of
expression should should go and sign
this petition switching gears a little
bit what have you learned about
distribution from releasing on freedom
yeah wow that's that's a like you know
filmmaking was a journey it's something
that I studied I learned I wanted to do
it distribution kind of you know came my
way because you know it's dip there was
no other option right within the
independent filmmaking world we are left
with so many limited options and so I in
in that I also saw an opportunity if you
if you look at Indian independent cinema
there is this amazing art house cinema
that comes out of India and there is not
really any company that is focusing on
bringing this cinema to North America or
internationally so I met a wonderful
veteran distributor mark Hermann and he
will see your think film and and we sort
of joined forces together and we say
we're gonna bring Indian Indian
independent cinema to North America so
that's that's I mean I'm not an expert
distributor but I sort of took the
initiative to start this company and and
Mark is sort of leading this the the
script to unfreedom was based on a poem
is that right that initially sparked you
to do a story right I mean Fez Emmet Fez
is a great inspiration for for any
artist I would say and the poem was was
written at the eve of Indian
Independence when India was sort of on
one hand we were getting three coat and
coat and other hand Hindus and Muslims
were killing each other so he wrote that
poem at the eve of of Independence and
as religious fundamentalism is sort of
one of the very key theme to to
unfreedom
that's where sort of that idea kind of
sparked mm-hmm what was the process like
the first week you began the the story
for I know I knew there's other
contributors to the script but you were
the initial write writer of it so what
was that first week like you you have
this poem in mind not really no no poem
was more of poem was not a story
inspiration poem was a thematic
conceptual inspiration I wanted to make
a make a film on identity and violence I
wanted to you know tell so so the idea
was to take two different identities in
two different geographies so on one hand
I took Muslim identity in New York on
other hand homosexual identity in New
Delhi if I would have picked one
identity and told the story it would
have become a film about let's say
Muslim issues or homosexual issues I
wanted to tell the story which was which
is not just about one of these identity
but sort of a broader philosophical
concept so the relationship of religious
intolerance violence sexuality and and
that's what that's what I was trying to
address yeah there was one character and
forgive me I forgotten his name but he
was this sort of Americanized transplant
did you feel any kinship to that
character he was one with the pool
business and he had the barbecue and he
had assimilated into
American life was that part of you and
that or am i projecting that that sort
of was the character I feel least oh
that's you know the perp the the
the way I set archetype characters on
both sides of the story there are
parallels with each other right and and
the idea was also to do to establish all
different kinds of Muslims on one side
and all different kinds of LGBT
community from you know characters on
other side and ellic on the character
that you mentioned he's a very political
Muslim character he all he cares about
his business right and and you know
having a happy life in in in North
America I don't think I belong there but
but in a way all the characters that
that you see in the film there is some
part of me in some ways you know at at
least the the six main lead characters
that that are in the film you know even
Sookie yeah yeah of course the artist
yes so Sasaki is a parallel character to
Fareed
they both are artists they both through
their art want to change the world they
they don't believe in a violent way of
changing the world so there they are
parallel on both sides and yes of course
you know I you know in this is this is
the question we artists face right how
do you change the world how do you how
do you do something that that can have
any effect in terms of of any change in
the world so of course I have bits and
pieces there